hello welcome back to another edition of
Mike plays the people we are accepting
one Oh
bullet challenges today no increment no
delay rated so hopefully uh you guys can
come and play me up I won't be playing
very long today so figure it out get
your challenges in and we can have some
fun okay okay he's threatening a big
check that's fine you know what I like
here I'm really slow and bad today so
should be very easy to get some wins
very very easy and then my screen is
very small I can't even see what's going
on hardly here
I'll slip all right yeah we got to
readjust the sighs I can't pre-move I
can't do anything I can't I can't
pre-move Danny come I can't free move
come on
oh I knew he was I knew he was gonna
play that moat - that's so funny
the one move I get the frame okay so
that was the frame of race that's work
yeah so the pre move is working ton
I got bishopman I didn't even want it
didn't even want your stupid bishop no
I'll take it
no I'll take it
we move like a chump we move like a
champ
the only way to win okay
don't get checkmated don't get checkmate
all right we have to adjust the screen
just so I can see it all right all right
let's see if we got any challenges let's
see if we even have any viewers and
we've been around for a long time so we
have no challenges we have one spectator
does that mean we only have one person
watching who 37 people all right well
how come nobody's challenging me oh come
nobody's Chinese all right we'll just
play create a game one little bullet
then get on with the show
I'm too slow for bullying I'm too slow
for bullying
yep see you later night see you later
see you later at least I'm up on time so
that's one thing I got going for me I
get this pawn back it's another thing I
got going for me I got the a file it's
the little things in life it's the
little things no I lost another pawn I
may as well get some lift let's try to
checkmate the King huh and that lose our
Queen you're still up on time that's
good all right we got the big Bishop
takes check going on now we'll try to
checkmate them
that's the name again we just lost our
rook it still just lost our rook all
right Ian sit we got the a file let's go
let's go
hello I meant to I thought my Queen was
blocking his queen unbelievable
unbelievable and I got back road check
made it all because I thought my Queen
was on b7 unbelievable still got back
row checkmate
how embarrassing okay Oh for two and we
got a challenge we got a challenge and
it meets all the requirements
good job Victor let's play
oh my yeah I can't pre move for nothing
there's a primo there is a primo
Arizona
I just lost the pawn but I got that pawn
it's gonna give me a big check yeah and
see it I might have to take castle on
that silly
oh my bishop cannot protect my guy but
he didn't see it oh boy
it's a tough day it's a tough day for
Michael J
yeah it's accessible pre-move hey all
right
I might uh might Jack say win this one
if I can figure out how
now very very very very unfortunate
oh I might lose now
yay plus four points plus four points
over back over 1900 look at these five
three standard nope five two casual nope
no challenges and playing one Oh
standard rated is there any way I can
read the chat or anything Danny maybe
after this game maybe I already started
this
oh I got you so I have to lean over and
yeah put it right next to you right next
day all right that way I can see what
you see what they're all saying how bad
I am they can fun of me feel bad not
real nice now they're all being nice
they've I feel sorry for me because I'm
playing so lousy I appreciate that I
appreciate
as a canoe fork fork fork
although I think if he just plays a
three I don't think I can even take it
but oh well
I'm down in exchange for my silliness
but I'm gonna fork them again
alright I can see I can see I can see
see what you all you guys are saying
crushing this guy I'm crushing this guy
psych another exchange just for fun just
for fun just for fun let's see who's
better two nights are two rooks but the
debate of the year the debate of the
year
true
ha
yep I can't remove forth nothing
oh and I could have taken his queen all
right we got some challenges we got some
challenges we need to have rated oh here
we are week
it's not the same without Jonathan here
or Caleb
I think I want a piece but who knows I
may I find a way to screw this one up
too
and a piece plus in exchange and plus
get my check yeah
alright we're back in the swing of
things now we're back in the swing of
things
let's see if but you'll see if the guy
could checkmate me now I've given every
opportunity to checkmate every
opportunity
oh my gosh Jack I don't want to drop the
Queen yeah another jack just keep
checking this guy till there's no
tomorrow
I know that's lousy
maybe you can just get a perpetual check
now I'll take up a prideful check if he
wants a perpetual check it can have
Hey
one Oh rated rated bullet that is yes
rated the only rated bull
if I lose this one I'm in a lot of
trouble a lot of trouble
this is my comers kind of game this is
my trap my queen though trap my queen
almost the trip McQueen well my guess
let's play oh my god oh my god did trap
my queen huh just about was embarrassing
I might as well taking the rook and got
a rook for it
yeah snuck out of there she snuck out of
there
some noxious get on with the show I'm
just kidding with the show get on with
the show the show must go
just don't lose okay just don't lose
cast I'll move 50 I like it I like it I
like bust open nut
how did I go from that position that
this position is beyond
we pray for the stalemate pretty for
this thing with me Mike Lawrence who
even Lawrence who could pride beat me
today bad huh like Lawrence is Lawrence
is a very good instructor for the Chess
Club let's get this guy no more messing
around we're on the road to 1800 today
start like 1920 an hour not good huh
it's an abomination
luckily I'm playing a 1,300 here so no
problems with this guy like I got the
double pawns Oh gotta save them got a
sable they're like gold in this position
they're gold yes let's just make a king
of warrior make them a warrior now that
guy's copying off of me and making his
King a warrior
well my Kings better all right thank you
you undone my pawns for me it's a really
nice of you
very nice of you very very nice you want
it you got it
he's under my balls again who is this
guy who is this guy I want eyes the man
double pawns I demand them all right
here we go here we go it should be good
for me
Jack oh he's coming in he's coming in
yeah I know Oh
Oh there's anybody's game it's anybody's
game
check make up now
stop checking me
get some checks in and that should call
it a day
yay
victorious I'll take the victories
however I can do King Satan okay all
right with God on my side I cannot lose
all right
the ultimate battle of good versus evil
going on right here at the st. Louis
chess club very exciting very exciting
oh it protects it just in the nick of
time you got a go you've got it go you
good oh we've seen this one before we've
seen this one before this is getting
good
this is getting good all right just
distract that Knight distract the knight
distract the knight
I can't castle but I don't want to kiss
they just want to distract the Knight g4
would have been better to distract the
night huh but they're still it's still
time yes and it worked good prevails
against evil once again yes yeah take
that guy down to size yeah that's a good
victory that's a good victory Oh drunken
lifeguard we know him yeah yeah your
sandwich is about to expire it's still
in your folder so come and get it I
think it expires tomorrow oh that's not
a free that's not a free you better get
rid of that LightSquared bishop that's
the only way I know how to win all right
that that Knights gotta go
castle
make my dark squares about as weak as
possible oh yeah I got a passed pawn now
I got a passed pawn and I got that half
open a file oh my god I guess I'll keep
my beep on but now I can't play my rook
to a whatever so with oh god you can't
you can't give me you're a pulling it oh
now he's gotta play e5 I should I should
have played something to him for him not
to be able to play e5 oh my God look at
how much time he's got on me
this is ridiculous it's like I don't
know how to play chess anymore the most
ridiculous way to play I've ever played
in my life oh maybe I can checkmate him
now my only hope my only hope is the
checkmate
all right give me another pass pawn like
her now he's gonna give me a check I'll
never forget huh
give me a check I'll never forget so I
made up some time but my position is
horrid
you got no checks you've got no chucks
Isaac chucks yeah do it I knew you were
gonna do it you're so predictable your
soap oh you got my queen who cares I
didn't even want my clean good game
Isaac with the first victory against me
on this channel unbelievable
all right who else we got why are you me
in the shoes
I gotta start playing faster and better
and I got a lot on my mind I guess we're
starting this spring chess classic
tomorrow and it's a tough day tough day
for Michael J tough day
and my producer is left thick-walled
left me Johnathan's left me Bensimon
doesn't even want to be part of this
Danny our producer just left the room
it's all falling apart it's all pork
oh if they to passed pawns even though
there's only one but they can pretend
that they're to just pretend I like to
pretend by doing that like to get back
over checkmate it so let's make sure
that doesn't happen again that was
ridiculous I owe my king just in the
nick of time huh just in the nick of
time
I don't even know if I wanted to trade
books there but what's done is done
what's done is done
oh yeah don't check
let's eat up all this pawn you gotta
make that king of warrior and I can
crush
and this is gonna be a textbook victory
for Michael come oh yay back on the road
to 1900 back on the road oh hey this
might help this might help this might
help if I can win if I can beat this
expert might be close to 1900 again yeah
he's having second thoughts about
playing Michael calmer huh they're
having second thoughts you didn't think
I was man enough to take his challenge
did you can't see that but I am but I am
but you're you just not up the task huh
you're just not up the task I accepted
it I accepted it can't say I didn't
accept it maybe I'll offer a drill I
can't offer a drill alright I can't wait
forever it's a live show it's a live
show
crankin let's see what crank uns all
about
he plays fast and bad so let's that's
good crankin gonna get you cranking
they're gonna catch you somehow some way
I'm gonna take this pawn Oh Frank
oh you saw my little trick huh you saw
my little trick my little trick
let's trade everything you want to trade
everything fine
deal deal you don't have any tricks I'm
gonna I'm gonna get on the one with the
tricks castle always Castellon move
twenty-two
how did you know I was gonna cast it oh
I'm so bad I just lost the pawn and
another pawn once one pawn falls they
all fall and I get a check-in that makes
me feel good for a minute I guess you
should just play Bishop takes pawn and
call it a day
yeah we'll see how this plays out
yeah I don't know I meant to do
something else all right no try to
achieve the stalemate position Oh ease
these letting me achieve the sale me
position
never take that pond only a fool would
take that pawn only a fool would take
that point yes that's easy as it looks
crank and it's not as easy as it looks
come on Stanley
oh how did I walk in a mate this is not
going very good today I'm even losing
the good old Isaac fronts you ever get
that sandwich out of your uh your folder
the free sandwich no I think it's little
good for one more day oh yes is fine
Oh 4635 there's two available I was just
somewhere it's somewhere yeah the baby
room the baby a real hot floor that
doesn't have a door 46:35 yeah
okay cool I get to say in the baby's
room on Saturday night so life is good
again life is good life is always good
at the chess club they'll always find a
spot for you alright
Dinka sotto you're up you're up you're
up the baby's room alright maybe we can
play the comer variation and life will
be good again yes comer variation
achieved notice I'm Way up on time way
up in material
and I think I messed this up Oh
check
now just cancel the old-fashioned way no
rush if he wants to take it I'll take it
whatever and I got a shot coming up I
got a check coming up that makes me feel
good he's making his king of warrior and
I'm all about
oh oh I missed it I missed it how bad am
I worked a DP three work two de three
are you kidding me right now kidding me
no he took that
like sneak that through can't sneak it
through
yep I lost again maybe I'm gonna leave
the building now maybe
all right he's back he's back I'm ready
to roll now no more losing let's get
serious now
so wait am i right am i down let's play
the best player we get who's the best
player we got dr. Snoopy all right I
can't beat a dog who can I beat let's go
you got my pre move on all right I'm
back in business I'm back in business
now no more messing around for the next
half hour so
I guess
oh you want that forget about it
come on that right there and watch this
go
to take our nap to take that's the
question that's the question
we're not crushing this guy I'm crushing
dr. Snoopy finally focused and into now
no excuses no more excuses castle castle
right into the open sea file just
begging them thing for me to give me and
he complies but I know I snuck up on me
yeah oh yeah that's two points I ever
got in my life all right
dee LaRue all right another whipping boy
I see four he doesn't know what to do
again see four
oh there's my pre move there's my pre
move I'm moving too fast for this guy
and we've all seen this before you've
all seen this before this is gonna be
great
he does not know how to defend against
piss you almost got me you almost got my
queen he almost got me here we go Leroux
moment of truth LaRue it's like check
that did not stop whatever you wanted it
to stop
there goes your castle over there goes
your castle what a castle you live in
what a castle
I'd be embarrassed for that castle of
you bears all right now I got a play
home now I'm out of tricks I'm not a
trickster
I need to get my queen like right there
oh and then I'm gonna check and then I'm
gonna check and then let's get on with
the show let's get on with the show
you can have my you can have well you
can have it all I don't really care
shucks you never saw that check comment
I Polly have checkmate somewhere but
can't find it
who's got the time to fight all right
that was I don't even know if I deserved
a point for that one you fell for the
same tricky always does so Oh bullet
brain one two three you think her you
think you're 2300 huh well let's prove
it let's prove it let's pool
I've sick of all these masters and
experts challenged me in that play
open up the file open it up
let's play something really bad
all right yeah I gave you a chance like
oh I could have just played rook takes
checks son of a gun and wouldn't have
won the Queen I hate it when I bow and I
could play Knight takes check just give
it up twenty three hundred just give it
up let's try not to lose here oh my god
try not to lose and the first thing he
does when he tries not to lose you you
called it lost you can play a big book
takes check or checkmate come on that's
got to be checkmate oh he could just
take it but he can't find it oh my gosh
oh my god pawn unbelievable I hope I'm
not your hero because I'm not playing
like a hero - do not play like a hero
today
okay this is not as easy as it looks for
this guy not as easy
Oh coming in to make fun of me
the last
hang out in the corner hang out in the
corner that's an embarrassment but we're
picking up MetroPCS can I get a child
out you know you just did MetroPCS so
hopefully you're sponsoring get some
money for that get on with the show
and that that was a tough loss to take
it was a tough loss to take
this is just getting worse and worse
Oh your battery's running low Danny
I might just take that
that computer that oh no the other one
another say goodbye to my rook then say
goodbye yeah I don't need that I don't I
need to get checkmate that's what I just
lost my other bro - okay here we go here
we but I got big checkmate coming so
there's nothing you can do about it
right let's just pretend there's nothing
you can do with nothing just free me
with this pre move it Oh free free move
checkmate checkmate that doesn't exist
now to get a queen so fast
how'd you get a queen so fast I had my
little run LEM 66 you're gonna be the
one that gets me back on my round here
how do I challenge you know that's a
good question that's a good question
just ask Siri how do I challenge
all right free pawn let's go let's go
let's go
all right you see a checkmate now man
yep we did it he avoided it he avoided
it
hopefully you're tuning in today to why
some bad chests we're live and from
Studio B has has not been the best
effort of my life but that helps that
helps
I am going to win this game I forgot my
strategy just play people in the 1000
region a then I can't lose hopefully
never say never though but this game I'm
feeling pretty confident
let's try to get a nice checkmate here
Chuck
I'm all out of check mates
Oh still not gonna be checkmate yep if
this guy didn't lose on time I probably
wouldn't be able to figure out the
checkmate let's see if I can figure out
checkmate here no couldn't do it
couldn't do it all right buddy got the
point maybe all right another chess
expert let's let's play the chess expert
and see what see what's going on against
the chess expert King cast 3r I'd beat
one King today the devil king or
whatever so let's see if I can beat this
King yes
yeah pre move live by the pre move die
by the Primos
but it doesn't mean nothing we've seen
we've seen if you're watching today this
means nothing guys go ahead take my take
to play it I'll play i wanted i goaded
you into that i goaded you into that i
don't know if it's good or bad but i did
it I did it
it's called consolidation
I'll take two-for-one any day of the
week
Big Shot coming up here big Chuck it
doesn't really do anything but whatever
ooh
that's not a tactic Bishop takes g2 is
not a tactic
Chuck
all right free rook nothing Oh free work
for him trick for him but it's not a
free rook cause luckily I have so much
so many bishops and so much stuff that
it's all good
just stay on a black square and life
should be good okay just stay on the
black squares fine I'm just gonna find
this guy everyone says I have to beat
them I'll just beat you okay deal
yeah checkmate yeah stumbled upon the
little checkmate so down goes a second
King today yes now back on the road the
1900 checkmate or 500 let's see if
you've got what it takes
no it does he want to play me yeah okay
he wants to let's play then let's play
see if he knows the little trick
he does know the little trick but the
little trick is so goofy that can't even
be considered good
we got a pawn back unbelievable
don't check you can have that pawn - you
can have all my pawns what do I care
what do I care
you're gonna have my knight - oh you can
have checkmate oh my gosh you can have
my rook - I guess he wants my other
Brooke because they won tonight for the
rook but at least I get something for
that rook
now you give him a check
my chances are pretty bad but you never
give up right here we go here we go oh
well that attacked in last very long
alright now we have to achieve the
stalemate position as fast as humanly
possible
'if
and also many checkmates this guy has so
the checkmater 500 lived up to his name
good job
I'm getting stomped over here today I'm
getting stumped
[Music]
all right I don't have time for this all
right who can Sunda oh you're back attic
and Sunda or i gave this guy one chance
before to play me I'll give him one more
yes
fool me once fool me twice
if you ask anybody I've been fooled to
so many times over and over and over and
he got me again and again
alright no we can play are here we go
here we go alright let's go into that
and I bet he played the king of one how
much you want that go get good
never take pin pieces yeah what do they
know what do they know what do they know
so you don't want that huh
shucks now we got king of woman do I
dare Casa leaders caste leaders so what
is going on in this position does
anybody know anybody care H for King up
rook up this is my only chance to win
here that's not even that good of a
chance
I knew he was gonna play that I should
have had a refutation if you place that
but my note my knew he was gonna play it
and I just let him play I need to get
some pieces they check coming up
everybody saw your little check nobody
cared though nobody cared nobody cared
nobody care what about h6 here does h6
work we're just gonna have to pretend it
does oh my god like five seconds
embarrassing go up with a check go with
a check
embarrassing who else wants like kink my
clock
the Don Joel all right let's see what
he's all about
all right go into like a slob or some
tonight
nice pre move up remove to lose appease
the genius
these are the games I like the way I
look like I'm so good at chess but
really I'm really not let's read the old
did someone call the dank mean guy I
have yeah whatever I don't know what
that guy say
Eric
I guess I should read the that's right
new Jonathan here idea
read the
let's just call this one a day and get
on with the show
one second all right big victory for
Team move victory that's how we like
alright who else we got Costa 98
that was my year 1998 as you all
remember as you're off remember never
gets all talking about 1998 no that's of
course when I won that Missouri
scholastic state championship
will he see Oh
this guy's way ahead on time but I'm Way
ahead Lisa in my mind and I guess that's
all that matters what's going on in my
mind
all right then once again to get rid of
my double pawns for me oh I do not want
to lose that but I wanted the central
Iseman tonight so if I give him a check
do I win
do I win distraction distract him direct
I did not get distracted he did not get
distracted oh I lost the pawn but gained
a pawn oh what a move
all right I'm finally playing good chess
again somehow someway somehow someway
I don't think I can win
oh he did not want to play that move he
wanted to play the other seat pawn Oh
oh I was off to the races and then I
messed it up come on come on
what we hidden something like I
represent yeah good good job good job
close the 98 i I had mate in Maidan 8i
everybody saw it
everybody saw it all right Oh Don Jose
not used to fast chest alright so yeah
if you're if you're not used to fast
chess or bullet just please challenge me
one Oh rate it please I can use all the
help I can get
cube Jack oh okay I got good good
chances against this guy
f6o yeah we all know never play up six
we all know it we all know it we all
know what we all love it I'm so tempted
just to take the pawn but they say never
play hope chest but yeah sometimes you
just got to yes it worked
obviously Knight to g6 would it just you
know been the move so Knight f6 Bishop
g5 you can't Castle you gotta play rook
f8 here and he saw it oh my god now the
guy starts seeing moves
oh my god you really wanted to take that
yeah yeah yeah
oh now I lost my bishop that's funny
that's funny
check now don't get checkmated please
don't get jack baited yeah he didn't get
checkmated all right
so plus one I didn't even deserve that
the checkmater played Jew I haven't that
played this guy's such really mood or
whatever so let's see if I can beat him
try to get back up to a 1900 here
somehow some way if he wants to give me
a pawn I'll take it playing slow and
silly and this is not a good recipe for
a victory I lost that pawn
that takes some tumble isolated pawns
why not oh you didn't even well um I
guess I'm playing slow and bad but I got
a check no I don't even have a check
unbelievable how how humiliating is that
don't even have the castle check oh yeah
don't even have the castle humiliating
oh my god I got checked again oh and I
can just get checked again but now I got
the check so so life is good for a
minute I got the check now he got a
check I got sacrificed and you never
know we got all my pieces all up in his
grill so you never ever know oh you can
just take my night
is he setting up a checkmate or
something
stop checking you
all right I have achieved almost the
stalemate position so this
come on stalemate come on still me uh-uh
checkmate black is victorious yeah he
got lucky
except chessy rash all right well if
you're uh if you're in the queue I'll
accept you but you're not in the queue
so how can I accept you how can I accept
you in the queue you're in the game
all right let's play oh this guy
interesting
you know what I want I want all the
double bonds yeah yeah I'm sick of
taking all these double pawns and then
immediately they're just like getting
rid of them for me you don't have to
help me out like that
Chuck it's not check and I can't even
take the pawn even if I could noxious
oh you did see that as bishop was under
attack
oh I just got checkmate in there
hopefully I'll play rook the f8 check
you know hey go for checkmate and a fork
me and don't be funny
that's try to checkmate him over there
now g2 doesn't work let's see of h2
works I'm in check
oh god I just walked in down
all right he's all right let's go for it
Chuck like just lost my rook and I will
just pray that he doesn't see that as
Queens hanging
and to see me up road to 1800 I think
this will take me to 1800 if uh if I
lose this one and we might just have to
call it a day here
all right well mister it's only a name
why don't you challenge me well we can
see and I'll make you a deal if I lose
against you I will not stream next week
how about that so mister it's only a
name let's play okay might come or you
are Perry all right let's see let's see
how bad I am
I'm all right after I play Mike Homer
you are bad why don't you challenge me
mister it's only a name I am calling you
out okay I'm calling you out and then ya
if you beat me mister only it's a name I
won't stream next week okay deal
got really weak dark squares here and
this Bishop trying to checkmate me or
something you can have that fly if you
really want that pawn so bad I don't
think you can even take that pawn
Trappist Queen to mr. Eastwick the
old-fashioned way the old-fashioned III
alright here we go
oh I lost something
get the D file and get out of here
I trade into a losing end game I like
that idea
I can't lose the mic Homer you are bad
and that would be embarrassing
thanks for the porn oh but he got my
pawn you got the good point
oh my god why am I going to the get the
Queen oh my gosh I am bad I am oh my got
405 points off of me oh my gosh how did
I lose that you know make yes
and then Chuck
man took too long to check them where is
that one guy where's that one guy mister
it's only in the name I want to play my
comer
all right challenge me then well do quit
talking and challenge me and this is the
day to do it because uh I got no chance
here
I'm missing my sidekicks I guess they're
helping me when they play they like hey
Mike don't forget about your paw hey
Mike don't forget about your night maybe
it's all them the whole time they leave
me alone just to die out here
port the game abort the game all right
I think this guy beat me earlier today
so let's try to get a rematch against
them
Oh bye-bye bishop bye-bye bishop never
knew you never knew you
my producer is coming out he might just
call it a day after that move big jack
big jack big jack
I can get back book checkmated probably
this is an embarrassment and it's an
embarrassment
some days you just don't have it some
days you just don't have it tell that
one get on that guy and tell that guy to
challenge me or whatever well he's
talking really big because I might come
back and win this one can you believe it
I might come back alright here's my
chance here's my chance to come back and
win it oh I still have a chance somehow
someway
just let him have that I was
should I gotta take that pawn I didn't
really didn't want to do that yeah I won
Oh
timed out even with one no no no a job
DJ no yo you gotta graded rated you want
these rating points today you want these
rating points even when I draw I still
lose seven points that's a tough one
it's a tough one where where's this
mister uh mister mister it's only a name
on whatever bathroom and smoked beer be
right back okay so he gets to get all
prepared while I have to sit here but
that's that this is pending okay okay if
he beats me I will not stream next
Friday oh my gosh okay so why don't I
you're all in why don't I take a break I
don't smoke obviously what I do well
don't worry about what I do but I don't
smoke so so I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
quick break is that allowed sure I'm
gonna take a quick break and I'll be
back and I'll play mr. only it's a name
and if I if he beats me there will be no
stream next week but if I beat him I'm
gonna be victorious for the day
everybody okay with that whether you're
or not he's out but I will be back
hopefully he'll be back to your beat I
know Isaac loves the stream no I I think
just loves to jump in there whenever my
color leaves just Isaac just loves to
play in front of the people I mean you
just beat my color today I'd cry you
deserve a share more than anyone on this
year I stole it who is he playing I
don't want even if left there the
person's like mana and
not there yet that's what he left okay
take your just play over right probably
do the five minute game because he won't
accept it yes
cuz Michael never play by and game lady
this one's all right Danny what do I
play what is this game what is it one of
my plays checkers checkers race checkers
no checkers all my pieces would be on
the same color
oh I'm I'm sure a lot I'm unsure let the
reflecto play the same pose as your
opponent until you win right
hello everyone wheelchair
they've yet to reply but Mike Lee pink
she's gone there it just loves he knew
that he needed to straight-up left just
get his ducks in a row before his epic
match not sure why he let the stream
take control over whether he gets to
stream anymore seems like a major
blunder on his part
yeah it might not really affect anything
cuz I'm not sure next week oh we have
the classics oh oh she probably should
have sat next to it anyways all right
maybe he maybe he was aware of that it
was me I don't know if you know I don't
know
so a lot nicer with this mic for us
because we don't have we can actually
just walk around and not sometimes ruin
people's ears wouldn't mic just gets up
and leaves
this is a quick think my Fabiano draw
wanna this is a deep position it's
finding the draw nope no no no okay once
you're out you're out you made your bed
now lie in it
you made your bed hopefully Isaac can
redeem the stream hopefully you might
just lose redeem his dream I don't know
man I don't know if I'm qualified for
such things
I will try no promises
I'm just trying to keep his pieces out
of my squares stay away no none of your
[ __ ] up s-- get in to my squares and
then your unites oh he's got all the
circles going very exciting I'm a very
professional streamer look at me yeah
we're gonna actually see it on the
stream yeah I need to develop my pieces
and maybe castle castle sewing is tends
to be good mm is this the funkiest move
ever let's try it
I think I'd get my Bishop on a better
diagonal intention maybe not
it was certainly the spiciest move on
the board
who knows if it's good but it's spicy
good take
you could play Bishop d7 queen c8 Bishop
takes that is I'm just kidding safe you
know what I'm just just castling getting
out of this maybe I need to the bishops
on a scary place for my king as well
maybe want to really make sure he
doesn't play d6 and put my queen there
or something but I don't want to
blockade with my queen rag you want the
bishop behind the Queen yeah I wish I
could put my queen on e4 and my bishop
on d6 but can't play Bishop d6 and then
you can't push and then I can play Queen
me there well this guy just really wants
put my pieces further forward I'm doing
it I'm gonna win can you see on the
challenge who's challenging us after you
take me my comer you are bad I already
lost the him he proved his point yeah
that's good
all right we're still waiting for mr.
it's only a name to challenge us one
overrated where do I want this bishop
but this bishops probably my worst piece
where do I want to I just want to try
and trade it off is there a way I can
get it to attack this pawn can i
teleport it to g3 g6 well you're wrong
this is the strategy this is the
ultimate strategy true to your name yes
indeed you are
oh drawn rowana Anish sk says ten bucks
says mister it's only a name doesn't
even turn up i believe it hey all right
my queen is there I'm not sure what it's
doing there he's gonna try to attack
this Palm Sunday I don't know I'll chop
up my night here
seems awkward for him to try and stop
that from happening
nobody does does he put it a rock on it
three
does that like do I care if he does that
the dream would be if he plays rook to
Chivo
yeah yes that's the tree yes
hmm I wonder if he heard me yeah even I
was looking at rook f3 so manyy now oh
and this is just a casual game well I
just have to play something while you
were doing whatever you were doing yes
yes well you were mentally preparing or
we were waiting for him to show up are
they for the big joke game for the
bigoted Joker just show up
mmm
how to win out a win
dresses too hard so hard to win
can't move my bishop because I'm
stopping work up five I need to prevent
that from ever happening
do I need to like push some ponds what
do I do well if you want your Bishop to
be good you play c6 right and just hope
battle but right now it's stopping the
brook f5 and I don't ever want that to
have that it's not really stopping rook
F uck cuz your Knights stopping that cuz
like haha yes
and I've ever really need to perenna
five I can play chewy six not that I
want to play j6 juice that's a big
concession
one can only assume
might eventually the purloined night
back on essence no no now that I've
committed I'm just in oh oh so you take
then I'll play e5 then you'll take with
the rope okay but they don't get this
that's why you have to have the Queen
and throne of the bishop
yeah I wish that was the case I don't
think I don't think I think the SAC is
unsound but for my am yeah take it then
you play e5 them for takes e5 and then
it checks manage yeah yeah
Oh mister only it's a name I just
challenged um whatever rated you love
st. um whatever - well we'll see we'll
see we'll see oh we got the big check
yeah
what's he so excited about that check
for I'll never know
well the bishop did his job you better
get that Bishop out of there it's only
in Oh Oh little hoax ass action a little
bit just love of chess I see you yeah
when you're going crazy you might as
well just go all done crazy how about
you
that's a good move
and then I go night cure
where that universe to
now I'll move his fish up alright have
22 seconds
check make it
Oh My look over here yeah doing a little
checkmate over here guys better start
moving
what there's no increment Queens hanging
big check big jack big jack I got it I'm
doing all right here
take it there you take it a dare you
take it an area well I got it did it on
the most
Oh God oh my god dude I just got a move
man ah there was no time for thinking
there was only time for moving I don't
know it was a very quality game of chess
all the way up until the end yeah you've
missed made into probably sounds like
it's thinking cuz you could add yeah
checkmate right there right there right
ake the bishop boom Chuck yep well did
your did your challenger you mister it's
only a name so so this is this is what's
on the line everybody if this guy beats
me
there will be no stream next week this
is scheduled for one fall
Game one o rated are we ready
it's zoned in and do this during
all week just
now there will be no stream next week
good night everybody
good night good game to Mister it's only
a name
no I should have taken that should have
taken it when I had the chance huh
that was a free queen stupid move there
shucks
well I made in check
now maybe I didn't
you do right yeah chat five including d8
so Chuck oh man you can even go to see
yeah same thing
help
that's that's life I guess life in the
big city hopefully I'll be back in two
weeks
but you never know
March did not start very well